[Musique]
les ruines qui n'ai jamais ressenti face
à elle ce sentiment si romantique de
méditation face aux temps anciens connus
bijoux d'époque qu'on croit pouvoir et
fleurie du doigt et pourtant éloigné de
nous par un abîme considérable que
ressentons alors lorsqu'on se retrouve
non pas devant des ruines les devants
une ville entière sorti tout droit des
entrailles du passé et présentant
l'antiquité dans toute sa nudité
tel est le cas de pompiers cette ville
engloutie en 79 après jésus christ où
les nuages de cendres vomi par le vésuve
ne représente-t-elle pas le plus grand
vertige qu'on puisse ressentir face aux
civilisations qui nous ont précédés
depuis sa redécouverte la ville romaine
suscite de nombreux fantasmes à vide que
nous sommes de toucher du doigt les
fantômes de pompéi fragments donne de
pierre portant avec eux l'âne ressuscité
de toute une époque
mais ce qui est intéressant avec mon
pays et surtout en raison du caractère
exceptionnel de sa redécouverte c'est
que la ville a alimenté l'imaginaire de
nombreux artistes et bien sûr décrivant
or si on peut constater que la ville
influence les écrivains il faut surtout
insister sur le fait que ses auteurs ont
grandement contribué approcher sur ces
lieux des rêves des fantasmes le plan
finalement toute la ville par le travail
d'écriture ont péri en effet est un défi
pour l'imagination des artistes une
ville figée dans la pierre à cause d'une
catastrophe unique et qui présente le
paradoxe suivant nous accédons en effet
à des morceaux d'antiquités encore chaud
à des ruines qui pourtant frappent par
leur silence puisque les habitants ont
désormais disparu depuis très longtemps
ce que je vous propose dans cet épisode
c'est donc d'étudier dans le détail les
représentations artistiques de pompéi
principalement ses représentations
littéraires
comment cette cité miraculeusement vos
découvertes elle devenue un objet de
fantasme artistique sorte de page
blanche sur laquelle les écrivains ont
projeté des méditations des rêves ou
encore des images mais pour explorer
toute cette histoire je ne serai pas
seul
clotilde de la chaîne passé sauvage qui
parlent principalement d'archéologie et
d'anthropologie accompagnera tout au
long de cet épisode pour essayer
d'analyser ce phénomène si complexe
qu'est la méditation sur les ruines
car finalement la question est bien
celle ci comment l'art et l'écriture pas
faire parler les pierres qui semble voué
à être noués
[Musique]
non
en 79 après jésus-christ le vésuve fier
volcan s'élevant en italie dans la
région de campanie entre en éruption et
entraine l'ensevelissement de plusieurs
cités romaines comme pompéi mais aussi
herculanum stabilo prentice
l'événement est d'une importance
considérable même si la région était
connu pour sa grande instabilité
cette éruption est d'autant plus
terrible qu'elle cause la destruction
d'une ville pourtant agréable aux
romains pompey étant une ville riche
opulente et accueillant de riches
familles si vous voulez plus
d'information sur la ville de pompéi
vous conseille vivement d'aller voir la
vidéo de passer sauvage qui lui est
consacré où elle parle de l'histoire de
la ville et retrace le rôle qu'elle a pu
jouer en 79 donc le vésuve entre en
éruption mais par chance nous avons pu
conserver les témoignages des écrivains
sur ces évènements de cette manière
l'éruption du vésuve entre doublement
dans l'histoire non seulement dans
l'histoire humaine par la re découverte
qui sera fait mais aussi dans l'histoire
littéraire puisque un auteur très
célèbre y perdra la vie est un auteur
qui a beaucoup compté il s'agit de pline
l'ancien hymne anciens était un
naturaliste un des grands esprits de son
temps dont l'oeuvre est incroyable pour
nous puisqu'il a rédigé un ouvrage
considérable encore très célèbre
aujourd'hui l'histoire naturelle
nous sommes énormes de toutes les
connaissances qu'ils avaient à
disposition inutile vous dire combien
cet ouvrage est précieux pour rentrer
dans la mentalité de l'antique
or quand le vésuve entre en éruption
pline l'ancien se trouve à mi zen et
observe de loin le panache de fumée qui
s'élève du volcan c'est par goût pour
l'observation scientifique selon les
témoignages que pline décide de se
rendre sur place pour prendre des notes
et comprendre le phénomène tandis que
tout le monde s'enfuit pline lui
s'approche de la catastrophe
il y meurt finalement vraisemblablement
à se fixer sur la plage mort pour la
science en quelques secondes
comment avons nous réussi à savoir ces
événements deux lettres écrites par son
neveu
pline le jeune relate dans le détail ces
épisodes pline le jeune les adresses où
célèbre historien tacite
il y évoque plusieurs détails techniques
comme la mort de son oncle mais aussi la
fuite des habitants et les nombreux
tremblements de terre la description
précise qu'il fait du panache de fumée a
permis par la suite de comprendre
qu'elle fût l'éruption du vésuve une
éruption explosive fait de fumer
asphyxiante se déversant sur les flancs
du volcan
pour la petite histoire c'est par ces
deux lettres et parti l'ancien épine le
jeune con la renommée ce type
d'éruptions volcaniques
en effet on appelle désormais éruption
plinienne ce type d'explosion faisant
jaillir de grandes quantités de
fragments rochus et créant de
volumineuses colonne de cendres ap les
colonnes
simian comme le montrent ces images du
mont sainte hélène aux états unis en
1980 ainsi ce type d'éruption possède un
nom qui s'inspire de la description
qu'on a faite pline le jeune mais c'est
aussi une manière de rendre hommage à
pline l'ancien à cause de l'éruption qui
l'a tué immédiatement l'éruption du
vésuve à un très grand écho dans tout
l'empiré romain
on sera en effraie et les auteurs
ressentent le besoin d'écrire sur des
événements aussi tragiques
c'est notamment le cas du poète latin
stas dont la réaction est très
intéressante
en effet il évoque le fait que plusieurs
villes étaient engloutis et plus
intéressant encore il se demande si les
populations futures auront conscience de
leur existence belle traduction sa part
quand on sait que pompéi et les autres
villes qui sont autour attendons près de
quinze siècles avant d'être
redécouvertes l'événement et ferait
tellement les romains qu'un autre poète
latin martial ressent lui aussi le
besoin d'évoquer les options il écrit
alors un petit poème commémoratif au
sein de ce qu'on nomme ses épigrammes un
poème dans lequel il dépeint l'ampleur
de la catastrophe car le vésuve a battu
la mort sur des terres magnifiques et
fertile
dès les premiers écrits pompéi est donc
une cité qui apparaît sous le signe de
la catastrophe ayant presque subi un
châtiment divin les provoquant en fait
un effet de sidération devant la
violence de tels phénomènes
et pourtant malgré ces témoignages la
cité tourner dans l'oubli très peu de
temps après l'éruption
peu à peu les villes sont engloutis
elles sont abandonnées et subissent de
nombreux pillages
pompey et même partiellement démontés
les pierres servant à construire
d'autres bâtiments ailleurs ce qui se
faisait très souvent avant que
n'apparaisse le respect récent que nous
pratiquons pour les ruines aujourd'hui
la ville sommeil alors pendant plus d'un
millénaire et demi gardant sagement ses
trésors d'antiquités
[Musique]
c'est alors qu'au cours du xviiie siècle
les villes enfouis par l'éruption sont
peu à peu leurs découvertes ont pays en
quelque sorte renaît de ses cendres
c'est l'époque où le mythe autour de
cette ville se développe et ce très
rapidement en même temps mettez vous un
peu à la place d'une personne au xviiie
siècle la plupart des lettrés
connaissait sur le bout des doigts
l'antiquité ou encore le latin depuis
des siècles l'art et la pensée se sont
construit et se sont même structure et à
travers des références antique ou encore
des livres et du jour au lendemain on
découvre presque par hasard des villes
entières pétrifié dans la pierre comme
une sorte de morceaux du passé qu'on
leur livre est dans les mains ce simple
sentiment suffi pour que cette
redécouverte passe pour un véritable
miracle scientifique et face aux
vertiges temporel provoquée par un tel
événement le mythe autour de la cité se
forment et se forment par étapes tout
d'abord de très nombreuses lettres de
voyageurs font état de cette
redécouverte progressive
l'émerveillement l'étonnement la
curiosité sont les moteurs principaux de
cette redécouverte perçu comme
miraculeuse
les premiers écrits dont nous disposons
ne sont pourtant pas à l'origine le
fruit d'écrivain à proprement parler on
n'en citer qu'un un certain charles de
brosses magistrats mais aussi auteur de
plusieurs livres un passionné
d'antiquités seront sur place et s'avère
être un des premiers à écrire un
témoignage de cette redécouverte en
novembre 10 739 il mentionne longuement
la redécouverte d'herculanum et fait un
bilan des fouilles effectuées dans
l'ensemble il s'agit d'une description
des lieux des procédés de fouilles et le
brave charles se plaît considérablement
à décrire les objets retrouvés des
statuts des vases des meubles intérêts
qui explique en grande partie comment
cette redécouverte de pompéi fut
principalement profitable aux
collectionneurs de riches personne
acquérant pillon joyeusement pour être
même dire la ville et ses trésors
mais dans son texte il est intéressant
de constater qu'il n'y a pas de vraie
méditation sur les ruines sur la mort ou
encore sur le temps il est peut-être
encore trop tôt pour payer à cette
époque est avant tout un lieu de
curiosité et d'antiquités en d'autres
termes la ville n'a pas encore cette
aura magique qu'elle aura par la suite
mais ce n'est qu'une question de temps
pendant plus de cinquante ans cette
découverte à une diffusion considérable
dans l'ensemble de l'europe les
imaginaires s'affole devant l'envergure
d'un tel événement un véritable tourisme
européen des buts pour visiter pompéi
une véritable mode née autour de ces
ruines avec la venue de nombreuses
personnalités vers ces lieux train soir
rennes se précipitent pour visiter
pompéi l'empereur joseph ii d'autriche
effectue sa première visite du site en
1769 où une fouille et mise en scène
durant laquelle on exhume des squelettes
plus tard françois 1er d'autriche s'y
rend en 1819 suivi de la reine victoria
en 1838 choses plus intéressantes
il n'y a pas que des personnalités
politiques qui s'y ronde mais aussi des
artistes et des écrivains lesquels vous
êtes responsable en très grande partie
du fait que la ville devienne presque
légendaire but le célèbre écrivain
allemand est le premier à s'y rendre
chateaubriand le suit de très près
expérience qu'il relate dans son ouvrage
voyage en italie où il fait un
inventaire des découvertes et admire la
vie romaine figé en 1811 le poète
lamartine s'y rend également puis c'est
le tour de stendhal en 1817 puis de
nerval en 1834 puis de flaubert puis de
théophile gautier
bref le voyage de tous ces auteurs
témoigne de la mode qui s'est créée mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
ville à cette époque devient plus qu'une
cité enfouie qu'on aurait redécouverte
elle devient un véritable objet d'art et
de méditation ont pays devient une cité
fantasmes et même s'il existe des écarts
importants entre les auteurs qui n'ont
pas tous abordés la ville de la même
façon de façon assez surprenante les
premiers auteurs semblent tout d'abord
assez peu enclin à rêver sur les ruines
montrant en intérêts somme toute assez
limité
c'est assez étrangement le cas de goethe
et de chateaubriand qui fantasme très
peu la ville et se contente simplement
de la décrire minutieusement de s'en
étonner
gustave flaubert montre guère plus
enthousiasme puisque dans ses voyages en
orient il se contente juste de décrire
parfois avec une précision démentiel les
lieux visités comme le célèbre
amphithéâtre flaubert n'idéalise pas les
lieux mais ces interrogations démontre
une chose
pompéi est une ville muette plein de
questions obligeant ceux qui la visitent
interpréter les signes qu'à leurs envois
mon pays une sorte de point
d'interrogation qui se dresse devant
notre regard
[Musique]
face à ce silence face au temps passé
subitement ressusciter son pays devient
très facilement en dehors de ces
quelques textes au lieu de méditation
sur le temps sur la mort sur les
catastrophes
grâce à des tableaux et grâce à
plusieurs textes qu'on pays devient un
lieu hautement spirituelle et une
représentation artistique pour projeter
les rêves romantiques la redécouverte de
pompéi s'inscrit dans ce courant très
fort de l'imaginaire mélancolique des
ruines un imaginaire qui se développe à
la fin du xviiie et au début du xixème
cet imaginaire a des conséquences sur
les pratiques littéraires mais aussi sur
l'archéologie qui est considéré comme
une discipline plus que scientifique
c'est une activité spirituelle la
fouille du passé et le contact avec la
mort comme c'est encore bien souvent le
cas aujourd'hui d' indiana jones à tomb
raider le mythe de pompéi se forme
le premier grand texte romanesque
consacré à pompéi apparaît alors en 1834
il s'agit des derniers jours de pompéi
de bauer lieten qui met en scène la vie
quotidienne de pompéi vu à travers le
regard du 19e siècle
dans ce roman historique l'auteur
cherche à redonner vie à la cité morte
par la création de personnage et par la
mise en scène d'une relation amoureuse
entre le protagoniste blocus est une
femme dénommée yvonne l'intrigué du
livre est assez complexe faite de
triangle amoureux de relations déçu ou
même de combat religieux est ce qu'on
peut dire toutefois c'est que burn in
town est un des premiers à voir ce geste
de vouloir faire revivre la ville par
l'art la ville chez lui ce peuple de
fantômes et il est l'un des premiers à
la décrire comme je cite la cité des
ombres pompéi entre dans l'ère des
fantasmes elle devient la ville
mélancolique paradoxal par bien des
aspects un texte qui résume à merveille
l'image d'une pompe est idéalisé lieu au
contact des puissances de la mort c'est
la très rapide description qu'en fait
madame de staël dans son roman corinne
ou l'italie en 1807
au cours de cette histoire les
personnages effectué ce voyage en italie
si stéréotypé au 19e siècle voyage
amoureux qui les conduit dans les ruines
de pompéi la description que fait madame
de staël de la zone très catastrophique
les personnages pénètre dans une sorte
de palais des ténèbres infernale aux
confins de la vie et de la mort vous
entrez dans l' empire de la mort c'est
ce que nous dit le narrateur un peu
comme si l'on entrait dans l'enfer de
dante ont payé dans ce texte et surtout
l'expérience du temps une mélancolie
face au temps qui passe et madame de
staël insiste beaucoup sur l'idée qu'il
s'agisse d'une expérience paradoxaux
en déambulant dans les ruines le
voyageur a plus que jamais l'impression
de voir la vie romaine en direct sauf
que les maisons ou encore les rues
renvoie un silence effrayant
toujours est il que pompéi dans ces
conditions stimule l'imagination
d'ailleurs madame de staël voit dans
cette ville un défi lancé à
l'imagination si la ville offre aux
voyageurs l'impression d'un instant
d'antiquités figée elle est surtout pour
lui l'occasion de remonter dans le passé
l'expérience de pompéi alors cela
d'intéressant qu'elle vient faire se
chevaucher les époques et c'est
précisément le thème d'une des nouvelles
les plus importantes consacrées à pompéi
et cette nouvelle s'appelle arria
marcella souvenir de pompéi de théophile
gautier théophile gautier est un des
romanciers du 19e siècle connu pour
avoir exploré les thématiques du
fantastique des fantômes ou des revenus
il se passionne pour l'antiquité et dans
les années 1840 cette antiquité dans ses
livres devient le foyer de ce que le
critique georges poulet a appelé la
rétrospective évocatrice il s'agit en
fait selon gauthier lui même d'une
capacité par l'écriture à faire revivre
le passé à le faire revivre de manière
presque magique et c'est l'écrivain le
poète qui dispose par son art de la
capacité à faire revivre le passé en le
tirant du néant où il était plongé
c'est dans ce contexte que théophile
gautier s'intéresse à pompéi puisque la
ville est par définition un morceau de
passer qui a fait irruption dans notre
présent en 1850 boîtier voyage alors en
italie et visitent pompéi ainsi que
naples et son musée c'est de ces visites
que naît la nouvelle arria marcella
toute l'intrigué commence par
l'admiration du jeune octavien pour un
saint de femmes pétrifié retrouvées à
pompéi et il tombe à travers l'image de
ce saint amoureux de la femme à qui il
appartenait ce saint est à côté des
corps des victimes
l'un des objets les plus prisées des
premières fouilles il s'agit en réalité
d'une empreinte d'un saint de femme
découvert dans les années 1770 dans la
villa de diomède ce fragment a disparu
et malgré des opérations de recherches
durant les années 50 on ne sait pas ce
qu'il est devenu la seule hypothèse
envisagée serait que ce fragment de ce1
se soit totalement désintégré suite aux
innombrables tests opérés par les
scientifiques du 19e siècle
commence alors cette histoire
fantastique si surprenante où le
protagoniste s'éprend d'un fragment de
femmes comme le dit théophile gautier un
amoureux trop spectre se développe alors
rétrospectif car octavien tombe amoureux
d'une romaine mortes depuis des siècles
cette fameuse arias marcel un peu plus
tard alors qu octavien se promène de
nuit à pompéi la cité reprend vie
progressivement les ruines redeviennent
bâtiment et la vie de ce peuple alors de
fantômes c'est dans cette vie
fantasmatique qui peut dialoguer avec
les anciens romains alors que la ville
reprend vie octavien cherche alors à
retrouver à rien marcel ce qu'il réussit
à faire de manière assez fun arria
marcella expliqua octavien qu'elle a
réussi à ressentir l'amour d'octavien
pour elle
par delà les siècles bouleversant notre
expérience puisqu'il est sous-entendu
cariat marcela a ressenti l'amour
d'octavien à travers le simplon me fier
du musée grâce aux forces magnétiques de
l'unir cette histoire à peu percé
s'appuie en fait sur de véritables
croyance au 19e siècle principalement
des croyances issus du magnétisme de
messmer des théories selon lesquelles il
existerait dans l'univers des forces
magnétiques qui régissent la vie entre
les êtres ou entre les choses l'amour
par exemple est alors défini comme une
relation d'attraction magnétique entre
deux personnes une idée qu'on retrouve
chez balzac et dans des expressions
encore courante aujourd'hui comme le
fait que le regard puisse être
magnétique
or dans rien barcella c'est bien de cet
amour magnétique dont il s'agit avec la
croyance philosophique que l'amour
dépasse le temps les époques
nous la relation daria marcela et
d'octavien dans mon pays
cette nouvelle fascinante montre bien
comment pays devient le cadre une
rêverie fantomatique très développés
puisque c'est par lieu ou le passé de
reprendre vie c'est aussi une bonne
manière pour voir comment les auteurs
font de ce lieu un endroit hautement
mystique à côté de tous ces écrits
romantique paraissent des publications
scientifiques qui donne une autre vision
du site et des sociétés qui ont vécu
entre 1860 et 1864 par est pompée à
nachum antique oui tatum historia qui
retrace l'histoire des fouilles du site
la découverte de pompéi et la
publication d'écrits scientifique marque
la naissance de l'archéologie comme
science ayant sa méthodologie propre
on constate aussi avec nerval ou gautier
combien la ville permet aux deux auteurs
d'exprimer des croyances mystiques de
réincarnation de retour d âme ou encore
de dialogue avec les morts le tout en
s'appuyant sur des éléments précis de la
ville et notamment le fait que sa
redécouverte a donné l'impression que le
passé était resté vivant
on constate aussi combien la
représentation de pompéi s'est
complexifiée devenant une ville fantasmé
puis une ville fantasmatique associés
aux délires et au rêve
[Musique]
mais l'évolution ne va pas s'arrêter là
on pays va devenir plus que le théâtre
de rêverie la ville va symboliser
l'inconscient lui même le fonctionnement
inconscient de l'esprit humain grâce à
un texte resté célèbre de sigmund freud
et oui il existe bien un texte de freud
qui parle de pompéi at on encore besoin
de présenter qui est sigmund freud à la
fin du 19ème siècle et au début du xxème
freud élabore en détail les théorie de
l'inconscient
à travers sa psychanalyse incident dans
ses essais s'est notamment penché sur la
question délicate des rêves de la
signification et de leurs liens avec les
mécanismes paiement de pension
[Musique]
parallèlement fraude était un très grand
amateur d'archéologie d'antiquités ils
visitent pompéi en 1902 puis fait la
découverte de la nouvelle de l'auteur
allemand
william johnson la gradiva en 1903 ce
texte nous le sous titre et fantaisie
pompéienne est alors le sujet d'un livre
restait très important dans l'histoire
de la pensée et de la littérature délire
et rêve dans la gradiva de vilaines
johnsen que freud fait paraître en 1907
il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de la
première interprétation psychanalytique
d'un livre et même d'une oeuvre d'art en
général
fois cherche en réalité à transposer
dans le domaine de l'art des méthodes
qu'il utilisait auparavant notamment
pour déceler à l'intérieur des oeuvres
des mécanismes inconscients actifs
cette oeuvre est crucial parce qu'elle a
ouvert la voie à ce type d'étude un type
d'étude qui est d'ailleurs fortement
controversé et c'est un euphémisme qui
consiste à analyser des textes pour y
voir le témoignage par des motifs des
thèmes ou encore des images en
fonctionnement inconscient de l'esprit
comme les plis d'une robe qui révélerait
la forme d'un oiseau et qui serait une
image inconsciente du peintre ils font
son analyse sur un tableau de léonard de
vinci la vierge enfant jésus et
sainte-anne analyse qu'il développe dans
un livre un souvenir d'enfance de
léonard de vinci
mais quel rapport avec mon pays me
diriez vous c'est que le texte que freud
étudie la gradiva de jane scène raconte
dans le même style que théophile gautier
la découverte par un archéologue nommé
norbert and hold d'un bas relief
représentant une femme qui marche que le
protagoniste décide de nommer la gr div
un peu comme pour octavien chez
théophile gautier norbert s'éprend de ce
tableau et rêve de cette femme elle
s'imagine qu'elle a vécu à pompéi et au
cours d'un cauchemar le protagoniste se
l'imaginent 24 août 79 le jour de
l'éruption du vésuve mourant à se fixer
convaincu qu'il peut la retrouver il
décide alors d'aller directement sur
place ou pays pour retrouver sa trace
toute la nouvelle est alors ponctuée de
rêve du protagoniste sur pompéi sur le
vésuve sur les ruines et sur la gratte
ivre ce sont ses rêves qui bien sûr
intéresseront freud
petit détail amusant on sait que freud
décida de se procurer le fameux bas
relief de l'oeuvre qu'il plaça à
l'intérieur de son bureau exactement
comme le personnage de la nouvelle
plutôt surprenante
freud dans son étude des plans en fait
une analogie parfois un peu bancal et
pas tout à fait juste à ses yeux mais
qu'il utilise pourtant la ville de
pompéi est alors l'image même du
refoulement inconscient fraude développe
son analyse selon laquelle la
psychanalyse est comparable à
l'archéologie de même que l'archéologue
explore et fouillent les différentes
strates du passé le psychanalyste lui
aussi creuse les différentes couches de
l'inconscient ont péri dans la nouvelle
johnson est alors la représentation
l'image de cet inconscient à découvrir
comme il le dit il n'y a pas de
meilleure analogie du refoulement qui
tout à la fois un élément cixi
inaccessible et le conserve ferme
ensevelissement comme celui qui a été le
destin fatal de comptines l'analogie est
subtile tentante voir belle et poétique
mais encore faut-il adhérer au travail
de freud et au travail du psychanalyste
mais le fait de savoir si freud a raison
ou non importe peu dans notre cas parce
que ce qui compte c'est surtout de voir
que ton pays a une aura si grande qu'on
estime qu'elle pourra incarner jusqu'à
l'inconscient lui-même
exactement comme le fait freud est en
quelque sorte qu'elle peut incarner ce
qu'il ya de plus profond à l'intérieur
de l'âne
[Musique]
oh
ce dernier exemple montre bien comment
pompéi pour de nombreux auteurs s'est
présenté comme un petit défi un objet de
fantasme assez exceptionnel capable de
représenter des éléments meetic abstrait
ou encore mystiques freud finalement
choisi de représenter l'intérieur de
notre psyché comme une ville que la
cendre est recouverte puis qu'on aurait
redécouverte petit à petit théophile
gautier y voit le lieu d'une rencontre
possible entre les âmes et les époques
tandis que madame de staël médite sur la
puissance d'un lieu qui rapprochent de
nous en passer
censé être déjà mort
toutes ces approches révèle comme un
pompier et devenu un objet d'art à part
entière un peu timide que l'on peut
décliner différemment même si cette
ville est restée dans les imaginaires un
haut lieu spirituel aller à pompéi s'est
alors plus que voir des ruines
c'est chercher à faire l'expérience d'un
passé qu'on rêve à portée de main il
serait possible d'aborder encore plus de
textes antiques sont nombreux à essayer
d'écrire pompéi de s'approprier les
lieux voire d'essayer de les comprendre
mon pays fait partie de tout cet
imaginaire antique qui suscite la
rêverie car l'antiquité au delà
questionne sans cesse le rapport que
nous entretenons avec notre passion
l'écriture semble le lieu idéal pour
déployer ses rêveries et pompéi en est
le parfait exemple
pompéi source de rêves un signe ou comme
le dit si joliment claude aziza
l'antiquité s'étend dans notre
imaginaire occidental du moins comme un
immense territoire du rêve une réserve
naturelle où vivent en liberté de grand
falls assoupi
[Musique]